rapport je tiens à vous faire part du
plaisir et de la satisfaction que je
vais devoir aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi examinée par notre
assemblée cette aide universel d'urgence
qui vise à combler un réellement lorsque
les victimes subissant des violences
conjugales rencontrent des difficultés à
s'extraire de l'emprise de leur conjoint
violents en raison de la dépendance
financière
cette dépendance financière peut faire
renoncer au départ ou forcer les
victimes de violences conjugales qui ont
franchi le pas à renoncer à revenir en
arrière
je dis notre proposition car je tiens à
associer les équipes du conseil
départemental du Nord qui sont ici
présentes avec qui je travaille depuis
plusieurs mois sur ce dispositif qui est
au final le résultat de nos nombreux
échanges avec les associations
compétentes les travailleurs sociaux les
services de gendarmerie et de police le
procureur la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales c'est ce travail de terrain
qui nous a fait imaginer le dispositif
proposé aujourd'hui et que nous avons
d'ores et déjà décidé d'expérimenter
dans le Valenciennois
je tiens bien sûr particulièrement et
également à remercier notre rapporteur
Jocelyne didez qui a su s'emparer de ce
texte on comprendrent les enjeux et
l'enrichir
utilement lors de son passage en
commission
le président de la République a fait des
droits des femmes et de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes une des
grandes causes du quinquennat à ce titre
le 3 septembre 2019 le gouvernement
lançait le Grenelle des violences
conjugales lequel a débouché sur un plan
d'action globale et inédit Madame
Elisabeth borne première ministre a
renouvelé l'engagement du gouvernement
en faveur de cette cause et il le faut
car les chiffres sont là et ils sont
glaçants en 2020 en France heure
homicide les forces de sécurité ont
enregistré
159400 victimes de violences conjugales
commises par leur partenaire soit une
hausse de 10% sur un an
en 2021 143 morts violentes au sein du
couple ont été recensés contre 125
l'année précédente cela signifie 18
victimes en plus dans l'arrondissement
de Valenciennes territoire dans lequel
nous avons imaginé cette aide les
statistiques du parquet sont
particulièrement inquiétantes chaque
année le service d'aide aux victimes
accompagne 1000 victimes de violences
conjugales
en 2021 les services de police et de
gendarmerie ont eu à traiter en moyenne
8 cas de violences familiales chaque
jour face à ce constat alarmant il est
bien sûr plus que nécessaire de
s'interroger sur la façon de prévenir
ces violences d'anticiper de protéger
d'agir en amont sur ce sujet je ne peux
que soutenir sinon inciter le
gouvernement à faire davantage pour la
prévention en lien avec les
professionnels de terrain pour pour leur
donner les moyens d'agir un vrai travail
doit être fait en amont et à ce titre je
remercie félicite mes collègues Laurence
Rossignol Laurence Cohen Nicole durant
ton Loïc Hervé Françoise Laborde Noël
Rossin au nom de la délégation du droit
des femmes dont le rapport d'information
présenté en juin 2018 sur prévenir et
combattre les violences faites aux
femmes un enjeu de société importé
énormément de propositions riches de
leur constat point de vigilance c'est 36
recommandations effectuées feraient une
excellente feuille de route madame la
ministre pour ren ces mesures de
prévention mais il est également urgent
d'apporter une réponse adaptée rapide
assez victime une fois l'emprise du
conjoint violent malheureusement établie
aider une victime qui trouve la force
d'aller porter plainte de demander une
ordonnance de protection qui trouve la
force de quitter le foyer conjugale
alors même que cela représente un choix
parfois tout aussi effrayant que de
rester subir les violences de son
conjoint là et le cœur de la présente
proposition de loi ainsi en créant une
aide universelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales on
accorde un droit à s’émanciper à
s'échapper de cette emprise généré par
une dépendance financière que le
conjoint violent assurel car trop
souvent les victimes de violences sont
contraintes de retrouver le foyer
conjugal très peu de temps après l'avoir
quitté faute d'autonomie financière
immédiate ce constat mes chers collègues
ce sont les professionnels de terrain
qui me l'ont dressé j'ai souhaité faire
de ce dispositif une aide universelle le
pré octroyé n'étant pas à condition de
ressources ni de statut pourquoi parce
que tant la victime éligible au RSA ou
que celle ou celui qui a des revenus ou
un patrimoine les moins de 25 les plus
de 25 les retraités hommes ou femmes les
violences l'emprise n'est pas personne
n'oublions pas que la rétention de
moyens de paiement ou de titres par le
conjoint violent et fréquent l'objectif
est donc de garantir aux victimes les
conditions financières nécessaires pour
leur permettre de se libérer de celle-ci
et ce le plus vite possible c'est
pourquoi le dispositif répond également
au caractère de l'urgence qu'impose ces
situations des conditions de survie des
victimes leur capacité à se mettre à
l'abri le plus rapidement possible et
déterminant pour elle-même et
quelquefois leurs enfants dans ces
situations plus que dans tout autre le
temps est compté le présent texte
invendait avec efficacité par notre
rapporteur Jocelyne guidez en commission
ainsi que certains collègues qui ou qui
ont proposé ou qui proposent des
amendements et bien prévoit ainsi tout
d'abord un délai de déblocage du prêt à
louer par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales de 72 heures soit trois jours
ouvrés madame la rapporteur cette durée
n'est pas un choix arbitraire mais juste
un équilibre entre le besoin d'une
solution à court terme pour les victimes
et la capacité des services compétents
de la CAF à instruire la demande le plus
rapidement possible
s'inspirant des mécanismes extra-légaux
d'action sociale de la branche famille
le montant retenu par cette annonce
d'urgence versée en trois manxualités au
maximum et l'équivalent du Revenu de
Solidarité Active je souhaite que nos
débats n'exclut pas celui de l'impact
budgétaire de la mesure proposée puisque
des critiques ont pu être émises et nous
nous serons faites au-delà du drame
humain et familial que constitue les
violences au sein du couple avec les
conséquences dramatiques humaines que
cela peut entraîner pour la victime
comme pour les enfants nous avons monté
dispositif
utile et financièrement maîtrisé si
besoin en été de le justifier l'impact
budgétaire sur les finances publiques
n'a aucune commune mesure avec les
conséquences financières d'une mise à
l'abri de la victime et de ses enfants
quand cela est le cas quand vous savez
que un placement une journée en maison
de l'enfance c'est 200 euros c'est à
dire 6000 euros par mois 6000 euros par
mois pour réparer et de façon absolument
pas satisfaisante une maman et ses
enfants on voit bien l'intérêt de cette
mesure de bon sens en outre un mécanisme
de remboursement mettant à contribution
l'auteur de violence est prévue une
subrogation serait ainsi possible de la
casse dans des droits des victimes pour
se constituer partie civil et demander
en leur nom la réparation du préjudice
subi l'idée simple faire payer l'auteur
des violences pour une situation dont il
est responsable enfin il s'agit là d'une
disposition vitale à l'efficacité du
dispositif proposer le président du
conseil départemental sera informée dès
la transmission de la demande à la CAF
afin d'engager immédiatement la
compagnement social de la victime aux
côtés effectivement de cette aide
concrètement ça signifie un
accompagnement global de la victime dès
le dépôt de plainte l'ordonnance de
protection ou le signalement par un
travailleur social
celui-ci sera la personne ressource tout
au long du parcours de rebond de la
victime car rappelons-le l'objectif
recherché non seulement de sécuriser les
situations fragiles mais aussi et
surtout d'amener une indépendance
pérenne cela passe forcément par un
accompagnement multidimensionnel
logement des marchés administratives
accompagnement juridiques accompagnement
santé psychologique insertion
professionnelle pour lesquelles les
travailleurs sociaux des départements
des CCAS sont tous désignés ils agiront
comme facilitateur tout en étant les
garants des étapes de parcours en
coordonnant les partenaires
c'était d'universel travaillée en bonne
intelligence avec les acteurs de terrain
permet d'offrir un résultat non
seulement opérationnel mais demandez et
fortement attendu par les victimes de
violence qui cherchent une mise à l'abri
mais aussi à retrouver cette
indépendance économique administrative
et par tout le maillage des travailleurs
sociaux associations structure d'aide
acteurs judiciaires qui se battent
chaque jour pour tenter et bien de
changer la vie de leur victime voire de
sauver des vies monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
quel que soit notre place dans
l'hémicycle quel que soit et qu'elle
soit nos convictions politiques nous
rejetons toutes et tous la violence
c'est violentes conjugales détruisent la
vie de trop nombreuses victimes de trop
nombreuses familles elles touchent
toutes les catégories de notre société
notre pays c'est toujours grandi à
protéger les plus fragiles les victimes
d'actes de violence c'était d'universel
s'adresse à l'ensemble des victimes de
violences conjugales quel que soit leur
sexe leur origine leur statut ou leur
âge elle se veut un moyen de rendre la
dignité de personnes victimes et aux
personnes victimes de relever la tête de
s'extraire d'une situation personnelle
qui n'apporte que souffrance et douleur
elle sera je l'espère si vous l'adoptez
tout simplement un moyen supplémentaire
et essentiel manquant à notre dispositif
d'accompagnement de mettre à mettre à
disposition de notre République pour
endiguer ce fléau et enfin et bien avoir
l'ensemble des conditions réunies pour
réussir cet objectif que nous appelons
tous et toutes de nos vœux
la parole est maintenant madame Jocelyne
guidez rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour 10 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues
la présidente Valérie Létard chère
Valérie a rappelé le contexte douloureux
dans lequel s'inscrit cette proposition
de loi en dépit de la mobilisation des
pouvoirs publics les violences commises
au sein du couple perdurent à un niveau
élevé dans l'Hexagone une enquête
statistique estime à 295000 le nombre
annuel de victimes de violences
conjugales entre 2011 et 2018 dont 72 %
de femmes la violence au sein du couple
est aussi prégnante en outre-mer une
étude de linede de 2018 révèle que près
d'une femme interrogée sur cinq se
déclare en situation de violence
conjugales en Martinique et Guadeloupe
la profession de loi en temps répond à
cet enjeu et plus de sa force dans les
retours concrets d'expérience Valérie
Létard en effet présenté le travail
qu'elle mène avec le département et la
caisse d'allocations familiales du Nord
pour mettre en place après d'urgence et
un accompagnement global pour les
victimes de violences conjugales
identifiées par les services sociaux
le texte est issu du constat empirique
d'un déficit à combler dans les
politiques publiques que nous déployons
en faveur des victimes de violences
conjugales il convient de les aider à
quitter définitivement leurs partenaires
violents en leur apportant une aide
cruciale dans des délais très réduits
les données issues des appels au numéro
39-19 violence femme info montre que 59%
des victimes souhaitent quitter le
domicile conjugal tandis que 18% des
victimes indiquent avoir effectué
plusieurs départs du domicile un
amendement 4 monsieur Chassin
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame rapporteur mes chers
collègues alors si vous voulez cette
amendement qui a été peut-être mal
rédigé puis dans mon esprit c'était si
vous voulez permettre aux mutuelles
agricoles de procéder aux côtés des cafs
au versement de l'avance d'urgence pour
les victimes de violences conjugales
ainsi si vous voulez le dispositif
risque de manquer certaines cibles qui
ont pour interlocuteur la MSA plutôt que
la cave c'est pour ça il me semble
pertinent d'ouvrir la possibilité au MSA
de procéder au versement de cette aide
donc cet amendement si vous voulez
demande l'opportunité d'ouvrir le
dispositif à la MSA et en fait je répare
dans cette amendement
sous-entendu parce que c'est
complètement évident 35 co-cignatères
l'eau interprété de la même chose que
moi dont madame Letare et madame le
rapporteur ont signé ce cet amendement
et donc je souhaite effectivement qu'il
puisse être adopté pour que les MSA
aussi puissent s'impliquer merci
bien sûr un rapport je souhaite bon
courage monsieur Chassin avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur
oui cherche chers collègues moi je
partage entièrement l'intention de cette
amendement au moins on peut en discuter
parce que de toute façon ça aurait été
tombé sur l'article 40 donc au moins
c'est simplement pour ça que nous avons
consigné avec Valérie Létard c'est que
je pense que à terme il conviendra au
caisse de la mutualité sociale agricole
de verser l'aide d'urgence à l'heure un
locataire et là je m'adresse bien sûr à
madame la ministre qui je voilà je pense
que là dessus on va s'entendre parce que
c'est vrai que il y a un trou dans la
raquette et qu'il y a important en tous
les cas chers collègues voilà quand
qu'on le considère mais vous comprendrez
bien que comme c'est un rapport je suis
obligé de donner un avis défavorable
mais voilà mais écoutez là je crois que
simplement ce qui est important c'est
que Madame le ministrella elle a entendu
et le message est passé voilà
donc avis défavorable madame la ministre
du gouvernement
monsieur chasse
monsieur le Président bonjour je vais
retirer cette amendement mais il s'est
quand même quelque chose de totalement
évident je n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi les articles 40 là-dedans
les personnes qui sont assujettis à la
CAF auront cette aide d'urgence les
personnes qui sont assujettées à la
messe malheureusement il y a aussi des
violences dans le rural et j'avoue ne
pas comprendre pourquoi on peut pas
associer la MSA c'est pratiquement
rédactionnel ce ça nous oublie c'est
tout mais mais bien sûr tout le monde
est sûrement d'accord pour ça merci
ah il est retiré désolé madame la
Présidente Rossignol pas de chance
c'est dommage
ah non vous pouvez pas
signature
vous pouvez
mais merci
mais je serai obligé de redonner la
parole à la Commission
quelques mois la délégation droit des
femmes a travaillé de manière comme
toujours dans la délégation de droit des
femmes totalement
transpartisanes et 4 de nos collègues à
ma connaissance on produit un rapport
sur qui s'appelle les inégalités
spécifiques dans les femmes sont
victimes en milieu rural je regardais si
ma collègue Mike harmonier qui s'appelle
les zones blanches de l'égalité la
spécificité des inégalités dont les
femmes sont victimes en milieu rural
dans ce rapport il est très clairement
identifié que les femmes victimes de
violence en milieu rurales sont
souffrent encore plus que celles qui
sont en milieu urbain c'est clair elle
souffre encore plus parce qu'elles ont
moins de tissu associatifs moins de
d'environnement de soutien voilà je
pense donc pour nous pour moi en tout
cas membre de l'élection droit des
femmes c'est une cohérence totale que de
reprendre et voter l'amendement présenté
par notre collègue Chassin
bon
peut-être pas Madame la rapporteur
oui mais vous ne changez pas d'avis du
fait de l'intervention de ses enfants
je vous remercie mais voilà vous savez
très bien que la Commission il faudrait
qu'elle se regroupe qu'elle décide
d'elle-même voilà je laisse le vote tel
qu'il est mais je pense que vraiment
c'est plutôt la balle et j'espère que
cette bonne
au rugby madame je vous passe la balle
et je pense que la décision vous revient
parce que c'est vrai que ça aura un coup
supplémentaire quand le veuille ou non
donc de toute façon ça tomberait sur
l'article 40 aussi
mais là on pouvait pas parce que c'est
un rapport voilà c'était un rapport donc
le rapport voilà donc je me tiens je
maintiens ce que j'ai dit merci
allez alors j'ai madame jasmin qui veut
s'exprimer et ensuite on va voter non
non non non pas de discussion dans les
laissez la parole à Madame jasmin et à
Madame jasmin seul merci monsieur
rapporteur je comprends les arguments
mais nous ne devons pas créer des
disparités une fois de plus parce que là
nous sommes sur un sujet sérieux la
proposition de Madame Valérie d'État
nous avons tous adhéré et je crois que
leur rapport qui a été fait par la
délégation de droit des femmes avec
l'ensemble des groupes parce que tous
les groupes étaient représentés
justement et de quand on regarde les
préconisations les recommandations de ce
rapport je crois que la proposition d'un
autre collègue et en parfaite cohérence
en fait avec ceux qui devrait être fait
donc je crois que Madame la Ministre
lorsqu'elle a pris la parole elle a dit
qu'elle allait faire évoluer un certain
nombre de choses et d'aller poursuivre
donc je crois que nous devons
aujourd'hui voter l'amendement qui est
proposé par notre collègue et après
madame la ministre va voir ce qui en est
pour améliorer je ne sais pas mais on ne
doit pas créer des disparités entre les
femmes améliorées d'autant plus que nous
avons été unanime unanime à dire que
leur absorbant méritait d'être fait
parce que les préconisations qui sont
faites et bien reflètent la réalité de
nos territoires et malheureusement les
femmes sont les victimes je crois avoir
compris quand même dans le débat si vous
voulez bien me permettre que
l'opposition de la commission n'est pas
lié au problème de fond mais au fait que
c'était un rapport et seulement cela
donc donc chacun sait dans cette
hébicide que les commissions dans le
Sénat ne veulent pas de rapport donc
après l'hémicycle décide souverainement
et je vais donc mettre oui madame la
Présidente l'état je crois que on a
compris
mais il vaut mieux redire les choses
pour qu'elle soit bien claires et
remercier le rapporteur c'est vrai qu'il
applique des dispositions qu'on demande
aux commissions de mettre en œuvre et de
la façon la plus exigeante possible elle
émet un avis défavorable sur une idée
qu'elle partage quelle porte parce qu'en
fait elle passe au travers d'un rapport
sinon effectivement on a une
problématique budgétaire qui fait qu'on
pourrait mettre en difficulté le texte
donc on peut s'accorder que Madame la
rapporteur tout en ayant émis un
défavorable enfin le soutien moi
allez on va dire que avec tous mes
collègues je peux pas vous laisser dire
que Madame la rapporteur dit oui en
disant non
non non non
président
exceptionnellement je voterai pour cette
amendement pour une simple raison c'est
que l'Esprit qui sous-tend effectivement
les explications justifient que on
marque le coup l'AMSA doit être intégré
madame Lamy c'est un message alors
madame la ministre allez allez on a
compris madame la ministre
merci de cet amendement alors c'est bien
je relis c'est bien cet amendement vise
à demander la remise par le Gouvernement
au Parlement d'un rapport sur
l'opportunité d'ouvrir le dispositif au
MSA en plus des CAF voilà c'est
exactement ce dont nous sommes saisis si
le dispositif est preuve d'efficacité il
apparaîtra nécessaire qu'il soit élargi
aux caisses de MSA par équité de
traitement entre les allocataires et
aussi par simplification l'accès à
l'aide pour les personnes victimes
relevant du régime agricole mais qui
pour ce prêt d'urgence sans intérêt
devront s'adresser à la CAF la
production d'un rapport n'apparaît pas
nécessaire c'est pourquoi je rends
préconiserai le retrait ou à défaut j'ai
mettrai un avis défavorable
allez je mets aux voix donc un
amendement qu'un avis officiellement
défavorable de la commission et des
favorables du gouvernement nous sommes
bien d'accord quel que soit les opinions
de chacun qui est pour
quiconque
il est adopté le Sénat est donc adopté à
l'automne dernier en première lecture
cette proposition de loi qui crée une
aide financière d'urgence pour les
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
le texte est ensuite allé à l'Assemblée
nationale où il a été enrichi adopté
notamment sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement puisque c'est aide
financière d'urgence fera l'objet soit
d'un don soit d'un prêt en fonction à
des ressources financières de la victime
et puis cette proposition de loi et
ensuite retourner au Sénat pour une
seconde lecture je vous laisse écouter
les débats l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion deuxième lecture de la
proposition de loi modifiée par
l'Assemblée nationale créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
des violences conjugales conjugales dans
la discussion générale la parole est à
madame Isabelle Rome ministre délégué
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes de la diversité et de
l'égalité des chances vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur mesdames les sénatrices et
les sénateurs nous tenons entre nos
mains un objet précieux l'un de ses
objets législatifs particuliers qui dès
la seconde même où ces dispositions
seront appliquées changera immédiatement
des vies parce qu'en cas de violence
conjugales il est toujours difficile de
tourner définitivement le dos à son
bourreau nous devons faire en sorte que
lorsqu’une femme décide de recouvrer une
liberté qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû
perdre rien ne puisse freiner son
courage
le drame de celle qui subissent au
quotidien la violence de leur conjoint
connaîtra grâce à cette proposition de
loi un facteur contraignant en moi bien
sûr si je le pouvais si nous le pouvions
nous aiderions chaque victime de
violence physique ou psychologique nous
ferions disparaître c'est emprise
mortifère par lequel les hommes violents
détruisent un petit feu leur campagne si
je le pouvais si nous le pouvions nous
aide rien chacune de ces victimes à
boucler sa valise
ce que nous pouvons faire en revanche
c'est agir en acteur responsable des
politiques publiques c'est ce que fait
le gouvernement via le pack nouveau
départ annoncé par la première ministre
des septembre 2022 c'est ce qu'a fait la
sénatrice Valérie Létard merci madame la
sénatrice en déposant cette proposition
de loi et c'est ce qu'on fait
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat en
adoptant à l'unanimité ce texte en
première lecture
je suis convaincue que ce texte que vous
examinez aujourd'hui en seconde lecture
fera à nouveau l'objet d'un vote
favorable et transpartisan je m'en
réjouis de tout cœur face à ce fléau
seul l'union fait la force
c'est pour que ce dispositif convienne à
toutes et s'adapte à chacune quel que
soit son parcours son âge son
orientation sexuelle son lieu
d'habitation son statut social ou sa
profession que le Gouvernement a
souhaité modifier l'article premier de
ce texte les principes énoncés dans
cette proposition de loi sont ceux qui
sont portés haut dans notre République
ce dont vous représentant du pouvoir
législatif et les gardiens
ainsi nous l'avons élaboré de manière à
ce que à ce qu'elle ne contiennent rien
d'autre que des solutions pratiques qui
permettent aux femmes une aide concrètes
au départ
tout au long de ma carrière de
magistrate j'ai croisé des femmes qui
n'étaient plus que l'ombre d'elles-mêmes
j'ai écouté leur souffrance des heures
durant j'ai dû juger arbitré apporter
une réponse pénale à leur calvaire
je me souviens de Gisèle séquestré violé
pendant des mois chez elle par son
conjoint qui un jour avec la complicité
d'une amie par 20 à prendre la fuite de
Solange qui parvint à partir à 75 ans
après des années d'humiliation et de
violence
j'aurais voulu leur offrir bien plus
mais ce n'était pas mon rôle alors j'ai
gardé leurs mots en mémoire
et je n'oublierai jamais non plus les
visages de celle que je n'ai vu que sur
photo parce que c'était trop tard comme
Leila
massacrer toute la nuit par son conjoint
devant ses trois enfants
j'aurais voulu aider les là à partir
ces femmes m'accompagnent chaque jour
particulièrement aujourd'hui
cette proposition de loi dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui permettra à
d'autres Gisèle Solange Leila de relever
la tête de recouvrer la dignité dans
leur bourreau les aspoliés
chacun est unique il nous faut apporter
une solution même au cas les plus
complexes
lorsque sera votée cette proposition de
loi viendra donc compléter et renforcer
nombre de mesures que nous avons mises
en place comme par exemple le pack
nouveau départ que j'ai proposé à la
première ministre qui a été annoncée par
elle début septembre et qui vise à
proposer aux victimes à parcours à
parcours coordonné afin d'assurer le
déblocage rapide de toutes les aides
auxquelles elles peuvent prétendre et
dont le président de la République a
réaffirmé le caractère prioritaire le 25
novembre dernier je pense également aux
Grenelle auquel j'ai activement
participé lorsque j'étais au ministère
de la Justice et dont la quasi-totalité
des mesures ont été mises en œuvre grâce
à vous nous irons encore plus loin
selon sa situation une femme victime de
violence peut faire face à une multitude
d'obstacles qui constituent autant de
freins à son départ lorsque ces
obstacles peuvent être levés par des
politiques publiques il est essentiel
que nous soyons au rendez-vous
car c'est aussi dans ce moment charnière
que les victimes sont les plus faibles
dans cette zone grise qu'elle ne
connaissent que trop ce moment où tout
peut encore basculer ou l'emprise trouve
toute la place de s'exercer nous pouvons
alors en faisant cesser cette situation
de dépendance matérielle économique
mettre fin à l'emprise et rompre le
cycle de la violence
car tous nos départs tout retour en
arrière peut-être fatal
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai voulu
que le prêt initialement prévu puisse
aussi prendre la forme d'un don
tout simplement parce qu'il est
impensable que la victime se retrouve en
position de débiteur face à qui que ce
soit du fait des actions qu'elle engage
pour se protéger
parce que le déséquilibre généré par un
départ peut faire vaciller une décision
déjà difficile à prendre et donc fragile
et nous voulons à tout prix éviter un
faux départ ce que nous proposons c'est
de poser le principe d'une aide
financière d'urgence ou victime de
violences conjugales cette aide sera
financée par l'État et prendra la forme
d'un don ou d'un prêt qui le cas échéant
devra être remboursé par l'auteur
condamné
ce dispositif émancipateur lorsqu'il est
attribué sous forme de prêt aura le
mérite de mettre l'auteur face à sa
responsabilité financière il pourra dans
le cas de la procédure pénale se voit
réclamer le recouvrement de l'aide
accordée à la victime
nous faisons reposer notre proposition
sur le triptyque de souplesse rapidité
universalité souplesse parce qu'il nous
faut répondre aux besoins de chaque
victime rapidité parce que notre réponse
doit prendre en compte chaque seconde
passer en compagnie de son bourreau et
que chaque seconde patient cette
compagnie est une seconde de trop et
universalité parce que nous voulons que
nos dispositifs soient accessibles sans
condition de ressources aux victimes qui
en ont besoin
vous l'aurez compris ce que j'appelle de
mes vœux devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
que nous admettons ensemble que protéger
nos concitoyennes du danger qui les
guette dépasse les clivages partisans
en votant ce texte de loi vous permettez
son application rapide en votant ce
texte de loi vous soulager les
souffrances de celle qui veut s'extraire
des griffes de leur bourreau vous leur
donnez le souffle pour partir vous
sauver leur peau
quel que soit notre appartenance
politique nous devons bike protéger ses
femmes
à l'issue de cette séance nous avons la
possibilité de sauver des vies nous
avons l'occasion de faire un pas de plus
en faveur de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes saisissons
là
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est
maintenant madame Jocelyne guidez
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour 10 minutes maximum
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 20 octobre
dernier le Sénat adopté à l'unanimité la
propulsion de loi créant une aide
d'urgence en faveur des victimes de
violence conjugales déposées par notre
collègue Valérie d'État moins de 4 mois
plus tard le texte nous revient après
avoir recueilli le vote là aussi une
anime de l'Assemblée nationale il y a
toutefois toutefois apporté des
modifications substantielles
la profession de loi adoptée par le
Sénat prévoyait un dispositif d'avance
d'urgence octroyé par les Caisses
d'Allocations Familiales sous la forme
d'un prêt à taux zéro l'objectif
poursuivi par cette avance et d'aider
les victimes à quitter le domicile
conjugal alors que 19% des femmes
victimes déclass subir des violences
économiques lors de leur appel au 39 19
en 2020
le premier des trois versements mensuel
constituant cette aide devait intervenir
dans les trois jours ouvrés suivant la
demande le dispositif et ses paramètres
étaient issus des retours d'expérience
d'une expérimentation menée dans le nord
par le Conseil départemental et la
caisse d'allocations familiales en outre
le test que nous avions adopté a sorti
le service de l'aide d'un mécanisme de
remboursement par l'auteur des violences
conjugales la CAF avait de la
possibilité de se constituer partie
civile pour le compte de la victime si
celle-ci est renoncé à exercer ses
droits afin de récupérer les sommes sur
les dommages et intérêts prononcés lors
d'un procès de pénal nos collègues
députés ont apporté au texte du Sénat
des modifications qui ne sont pas
négligeables certaines ont été portées
par le gouvernement qui a cette occasion
est sorti de la réserve dont il avait
fait preuve devant nous toutefois la
proposition de loi a gardé un TAC
l'ambition de données aux victimes de
violences conjugales dans un délai très
court les moyens financiers pour se
séparer du conjoint violent c'est
pourquoi la Commission adoptée cette
propulsion sans modification pour
permettre son application rapide
l'article premier du texte qui porte le
dispositif de l'aide d'urgence a fait
l'objet d'un amendement de rédaction
globale de gouvernement sous un Vendée à
de nombreuses reprises il faut souligner
d'emblée les motifs de satisfaction du
texte qui nous a été transmis le
financement de l'aide d'urgence a été
transféré de la Caisse nationale des
allocations familiales à l'état qui
assumera là une mission qui lui incombe
naturellement l'Assemblée nationale a
également affirmé le droit de toute
victime conjugale a bénéficié d'un
accompagnement global enfin le
gouvernement a pu proposer des
modifications que nous appelions de nos
vœux mais que les règles de recevabilité
financière nous nous permettait pas de
réaliser je ne par exemple les caisses
de la mutualité sociale agricole se
trouve désormais intégrée au service de
cette nouvelle aide ce qui est
nécessaire afin d'atteindre leur
allocataire
par les caisses sur le terrain enfin
toujours à l'article premier le
mécanisme de récupération de l'aide a
été amendée en conservant le principe de
demander le paiement à l'auteur des
violences lorsque l'aide est versée sous
la forme d'un prêt dorénavant le
remboursement fait partie des peines que
les juridictions pénales peuvent
prononcer contre l'auteur reconnu
coupable ainsi que les dispositifs à la
main des parquets dans le cas d'un
classement sous conditions de la
procédure ou de mesure de composition
pénale la navette a donc enrichi
l'article premier de nouvelles
dispositions toutefois comme vous pouvez
le constater elle demeure fidèle à
l'objectif du texte adopté par le Sénat
nos collègues députés ont d'ailleurs
maintenu inchangé les conditions
d'octroi de l'aide d'urgence ainsi que
le bénéfice au droit et aide accessoires
au RSA qui accompagne le versement de
l'aide pécuniaire un article 2 les
députés ont maintenu l'obligation faite
au gendarmes et policiers d'informer la
victime déposant plainte de la
possibilité de demander l'aide d'urgence
en revanche si l'enregistrement à la
demande dans le commissariat ou
gendarmerie demeure une faculté elle
n'est plus systématique sans doute les
députés ont-ils estimé que de telles
dispositions ne seraient pas appliquées
par la norme contraignante mais par les
engagements volontaires des acteurs du
terrain d'autres dispositions de la
propulsion de loi concernent son
applicabilité aux autres mères comme
vous le savez mes chers collègues en
propulsion les victimes de violences
conjugales sont encore plus nombreuses
en outre-mer que dans l'Hexagone
l'article premier bis habilite ainsi le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
pour adapter la loi à Mayotte enfin
l'Assemblée nationale a inséré quelques
nouveaux articles pour avoir examiné ces
dispositions aux commissions la
sincérité m'oblige à dire que leur
pertinence et toute relative mais ces
dispositions sont annexes au dispositif
de l'aide d'urgence et ne gênent pas son
application
l'article premier terme propose ainsi
que une loi de programmation
pluriannelle détermine la proport
trajectoire des finances publiques en
matière de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes pour symbolique et
médiatique soit cette disposition elle
est dépourvue de port alternative le
gouvernement ne pouvant
constitutionnellement est tenu de
déposer un tel projet de loi enfin les
articles de terre et de quaters sont des
demandes de rapport sur lesquelles une
fois n'est pas coutume la Commission a
été indulgente en deuxième lecture la
Commission a donc adopté sans
modification le texte se transmis en
raison du maintien de l'essentiel de la
propulsion de loi a dotée par le Sénat
et des améliorations introduites par la
navette parlementaire nous nous
réjouissons notamment de la suppression
de l'article 3 par un rendement du
gouvernement permettant ainsi de lever
le gage financier une adoption conforme
du texte aujourd'hui signifierait une
belle avancée d'initiative sénatoriale
dans la lutte contre les violences
conjugales
issues de l'expérience de nos
territoires cette proposition de loi qui
entrera en vigueur au plus tard neuf
mois après sa promotion viendra
utilement compléter les dispositifs
existants c'est pourquoi la Commission
vous invite à adopter la profession de
loi dans les mêmes termes que
l'Assemblée nationale je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Laurence
Rossignol pour le groupe socialiste pour
6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
vice-président de la commission
je suis d'abord je voudrais renouveler à
notre collègue Valérie d'État nous
remerciements et pour sa rédaction pour
le dépôt de cette proposition de loi
pour son obstination et l'énergie
qu'elle a mise à la faire adoptée la
vigilance qu'elle a exercé sur le
parcours du texte et me réjouir
aujourd'hui que cette proposition de loi
soit adoptée il est temps que la navette
parlementaire s'arrête que le texte soit
adopté promulgué et mise en oeuvre les
femmes l'attendent et nous avons là un
bon texte je crois que nous allons
déboucher aujourd'hui l'un des premiers
écueils à la dénonciation des violences
subies et la crainte de devoir quitter
le domicile et de se retrouver sans
ressources dans une précarité matérielle
et qui pose une question de survie
quotidienne et cette crainte est
d'autant plus grande et accrue que la
femme des enfants à charge et cette
crainte peut être suffisamment forte
peut être si forte que les femmes ne
vont pas demander d'aide elles ne vont
pas dénoncer leur calvaire elles ne vont
elles vont se résigner à rester au
domicile conjugal domicile conjugale qui
est désormais pour elle une prison où
les enferment l'auteur de ces violences
c'est notamment pour cette raison que la
défense de l'indépendance économique des
femmes plus globalement et crucial c'est
une étape indispensable dans
l'émancipation que les femmes soient ou
non victimes de violence nous avons
progressé à grands pas sur le sujet
grâce aux mobilisations féministes accès
aux comptes bancaires droit de
travailler sans consentement du mari
suppression des interdictions
professionnelles faites aux femmes etc
etc la liste est longue et réjouissante
nous poursuivons cette mobilisation à
travers différentes initiatives pour
avancer sur le chemin de l'égalité
profession personnel faire tomber les
stéréotypes qui entravent l'orientation
des filles et en cette journée consacrée
au numérique je souhaite attirer
l'attention du Sénat sur la faible part
de femmes dans le numérique dans ces
métiers de demain et qui nous prive d'un
nombre d'ingénieurs importants si les
femmes s'engagées dans ces métiers qui
prive ce secteur de ressources humaines
et qui prive les femmes d'accès à des
métiers qui seront demain des métiers
importants dans ces mesures que nous
devons encore prendre pour éliminer les
inégalités salariales accompagner les
mermonoparentales défendre
l'augmentation des bas salaires nous
avons déjà des outils et je c'est pour
ça que je défends régulièrement quelques
propositions comme la décongèganisation
de la location de soutien familiale ou
encore l'augmentation du SMIC puisque je
rappelle que 60% des salariés au SMIC
sont des femmes augmenter le SMIC cette
augmenter les salaires des femmes mes
chers collègues nous fêtons années les
cinq ans du mouvement me too grâce aux
témoignages grâce aux mouvements
féministe grâce à la mobilisation des
associations et de l'ensemble de la
société grâce à la mobilisation des
pouvoirs publics et j'ajouterai
maintenant grâce à la mobilisation des
collectivités locales qui est un élément
nouveau dans la lutte contre les
violences intra familiales j'ai observé
d'abord cette année au Congrès des
Maires de France un atelier était
consacré nous y étions madame la
ministre à la manière dont les
collectivités locales pouvaient
s'impliquer et je vois sur le terrain
dans mon propre département que c'est un
sujet en lien avec la gendarmerie
d'ailleurs le plus souvent des délégués
droits des femmes dont les collectivités
locales les EPCI s'emparent qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire comment comment
rapporter une réponse trois types de
violences conjugales concernent les
collectivités locales celles dont sont
victimes les habitants de leur commune
celle dont sont victimes les salariés
les fonctionnaires territoriales dans
commune ou leur collectivité locale et
enfin celle subit par les conseillers
municipales et les élus et sujet parfois
plus difficiles celles effectuées par
des collègues conseillers municipaux
malheureusement les statistiques
globales ne sont pas différentes dans
chaque catégorie chaque échelon de la
société nous retrouvons strictement les
mêmes mais je trouve que cette
mobilisation des collectivités locales
est un élément fort important et tout à
fait
encourageant pour éradiquer les
violences faites aux femmes je voudrais
pas trop disgresser mais nous avons
encore beaucoup de chantiers la
restriction des modalités d'exercice de
l'autorité parentale et du droit de
visite et d'hébergement
l'exclusion de la résidence principale
de l'enfant chez l'auteur de violence
l'augmentation de la durée de la portée
des conditions d'accès à l'ordonnance de
protection la dissimulation de l'adresse
de résidence et de l'école des enfants
Alex conjoint violent
le signalement à la victime de la remise
en liberté de son agresseur présumée le
renforcement de la lutte contre les
violences de post séparation
l'abrogation du délit de non
représentation d'enfants qui est une
arme à fragmentation contre les femmes
aujourd'hui contre les mers qui
protègent leurs enfants et enfin le très
beau chantier madame la ministre dont je
connais votre engagement pour lequel je
connais votre engagement votre volonté
d'aboutir de réussir et aux côtés nous
serons à vos côtés pour le faire celui
de la mise en place d'une justice d'une
juridiction spécialisée en matière de
violence intrafamiliale conjugale et
sexuelle qui rassemble juste civile et
justice pénale la création d'une aide
financière d'urgence à son des victimes
et donc un moyen concret immédiat ça ne
résout pas tout mais c'est essentiel ce
que vous avez proposé aujourd'hui madame
chers collègues Valérie léthard je
voudrais dire enfin que la violence les
violences contre les femmes coûtent 3,3
milliards d'euros par an à la société et
que donc les sommes que nous allons
engager par l'intermédiaire des Caisses
d'allocations familial sont bien peu
comparés au coût collectifs que nous
assumons du fait de ces violences je
vous remercie chers collègues merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
CRCE pour 4 minutes
la proposition de loi créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
de violence conjugales que nous
examinons aujourd'hui en nouvelle
lecture aura connu un parcours les plus
tumultueux cette proposition de loi de
notre collègue Valérie l'état reprenait
une proposition de loi déposée par ma
collègue Michel legréeau en février 2021
je veux les en remercier ainsi que notre
rapporteur Jocelyne guidès face aux
nombreuses insuffisances de l'action
publique en matière de lutte contre les
violences conjugales le gouvernement a
déposé fait adopter un amendement visant
à réécrire intégralement l'article
premier nous saluons le fait que
plusieurs amendements GDR nos homologues
à l'Assemblée nationale aient été
adoptés pour encore enrichir le texte et
supprimer la condition que le
gouvernement avait instauré sur la
régularité au séjour et sur les
difficultés financières immédiates une
aide universelle se doit de l'être même
si elle est moduler en fonction des
besoins le la présence d'enfants à
charge était pris en compte et que ce
soit l'état et non plus la CNAV qui gère
ses dépenses de l'aide sont également
des mesures positives l'introduction de
l'article premier terre qui prévoit une
loi de programmation pluriannuelle de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes en ciblant l'accompagnement
psychologique et social l'hébergement la
formation est extrêmement importante
madame la ministre même son caractère
normatif pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
cette loi verra le jour avec les moyens
nécessaires que cela soit pour le 39 19
comme cela d'ailleurs est prévu comme
pour l'ensemble des associations qui
nous alertent les groupes LR et
centrices à l'Assemblée nationale ont
également enrichi cette PPL et si
j'ajoute enfin que plusieurs amendements
du groupe socialiste ont complété le
texte en précisant notamment que
l'accord de la victime était nécessaire
avant l'information du président du
conseil départemental vous aurez là un
texte largement transpartisan cette
construction partagée s'explique en
grande partie par la progression des
violences conjugales dans notre pays
selon l'Observatoire national des
violences faites aux femmes 213.000
femmes ont été victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelles commises par leur
partenaire ou ex-partenaires en 2019 le
ministère de l'intérieur par a fait
paraître une alerte sur l'augmentation
de 20% en 2021 par rapport à 2020 du
nombre des féminicides 122 de nos soeurs
nos mères nos cousines nos voisines nos
filles nos amis sont décédés sous les
coups d'un conjoint ou ex-conjoint
contre 102 en 2020 par conséquent il est
indispensable d'accompagner les victimes
de violences conjugales à sortir de
l'emprise morale et économique exercée
par le conjoint l'instauration d'une
aide financière d'urgence aux victimes
permettra donc d'encourager cette
démarche de départ salvatrice nous ne
pouvons que regretter madame la ministre
permettez-moi de revenir là-dessus que
la grande cause du quin d'Emmanuel
Macron ne bénéficient pas des 2
milliards d'euros qui sont demandés par
les associations féministes afin
d'engager une lutte véritablement
efficace contre les violences en
agissant sur l'éducation et la
prévention plutôt que d'attendre
l'apparition des comportements violents
et je vais profiter de ce moment pour
insister madame la ministre sur un fait
important si nous voulons et je sais que
c'est votre objectif débarrasser notre
société de ce fléau je vous appelle à
soumettre au Parlement assez rapidement
un projet de loi cadre sur les violences
faites aux femmes en vous appuyant sur
le travail qui est fait par les
associations féministes et notamment le
collectif national des droits des femmes
c'est mon souhait c'est notre souhait je
crois que nous le partageons en
attendant les sénatrices et sénateurs de
mon groupe le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste votera
favorablement ce texte en espérant une
adoption conforme pour une entrée en
vigueur le plus rapidement possible je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant à la présidente
Valérie l'État pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
madame la rapporteur chers collègues
nous voici arrivés à la fin du processus
d'examen de la proposition de loi sur
l'aide d'universel d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales que
j'ai souhaité avec l'aide de mon groupe
porté au débat devant le Parlement et
dans un délai record Laurence Rossignol
l'a signalé en madame la rapporteur
aussi en 4 mois à peine c'est assez
extraordinaire pour ce type d'exercice
c'est forcément aussi avec un sentiment
particulier une émotion certaine sincère
que je prends la parole pour exprimer un
mélange satisfaction de joie de fierté
partagée qui m'en parle à ce moment de
nos débats
qu'une initiative de terrain qui s'est
construite grâce à un travail nourri par
les professionnels de mon territoire à
l'expertise de nos administrateurs qui
ont su à travers d'échanges
d'expériences d'expertise traduire une
volonté d'aboutir à un texte
adapté à la réalité quotidienne que
vivent les professionnels dans leur
action auprès des victimes de violence
et bien évidemment aussi trop souvent de
leurs enfants
un texte qui je l'espère nous l'espérons
tous contribuera à changer la vie et le
destin de nombreuses de trop nombreuses
victimes sous emprise grâce à une aide
financière qui devra être simple d'accès
et dont le montant et les modalités
madame la ministre devront au travers du
décret que vous avez la grande
responsabilité de mettre en oeuvre être
à la hauteur des besoins une aide
universelle qui pourra prendre la forme
d'une aide non remboursable ou d'un prêt
partiellement ou totalement remboursable
vous en avez changé les mots madame la
ministre ont remplaçant cette notion de
pré bénéficiant de remise totale ou de
réduction en une un don une aide non
remboursable ou un prêt
sans intérêt le but vous en conviendrez
et le même c'est un soutien financier
ambitieux accessible rapide et lisible
facile d'utilisation par les
professionnels permettant de libérer de
l'emprise financière de
celles et ceux qui en sont victimes
pendant cette période de répète pendant
une période nécessaire pour rétablir les
droits de ceux qui les ont perdu de
cette absence de financement dans
l'urgence il n'y a pas de classe pas de
milieu pas de génération pas de
situation socioprofessionnelle qui soit
épargnés par cette triste réalité des
violences au sein du couple
l'universalité était donc essentielle à
mes yeux à nos yeux peut-on exclure une
femme salariée privée de ses propres
ressources une jeune de moins de 25 ans
qui a pas de droit au RSA une personne
retraitée non et donc ce dispositif
imaginé universel et rapide à visant à
exclure aucune victime quelle que soit
sa réalité était indispensable merci
Madame la rapporteur merci aussi à
monsieur le Président vous saluerez
aussi madame la Présidente pour l'écoute
attentive qu'a eu la Commission et bien
évidemment si nos collègues pour
entendre nourrir enrichir des
amendements l'univers de
l'investissement de nos collègues sur ce
texte votre écoute vos avancées n'ont
fait que renforcer encore la portée de
ce texte notre unanimité en première
lecture a été inspirante et a permis je
pense au gouvernement madame la ministre
et bien de changer la position des
parties plutôt réservés et de vous
donner la possibilité d'aller plus loin
l'Assemblée nationale et on peut
remercier aussi la présidente de
l'Assemblée qui a su créer les
conditions d'un examen trans partisan et
un vote unanime après des modifications
apportées par les rapporteurs et je
salue ma collègue Béatrice Descamps qui
était rapporteur et qui est ma collègue
du Nord les différents groupes aussi de
l'Assemblée vous l'avez dit Madame Cohen
ont apporté et nourri ce texte et ils
ont réintégré des dispositions qui
n'étaient pas toutes dans la position et
dans l'amendement du Gouvernement cela
permet d'avoir rajouté l'accompagnement
social des professionnels les droits
sociaux liés qui sont indispensables une
transmission de la demande simplifiée à
la CAF et au département et aussi madame
la ministre vous remercier évidemment
d'avoir maintenu la possibilité de se
retourner sur l'auteur des violences
pour le remboursement ou encore d'avoir
levé les gages pour la familiarisation
et possibilité aussi donner à la MSA de
gérer ses propres ressortissants
uneanimité au Sénat et à l'Assemblée la
montre que même dans les périodes de
tension l'intérêt général et la portée
des sujets tels que celui qui nous
réunit transcende les courants et montre
le sens des responsabilités de nos
assemblées c'est un bel exemple dans les
moments que nous vivons la loi doit
protéger les plus fragiles d'entre nous
ce principe essentiel m'a toujours guidé
et si vous êtes là à cet instant et si
vous tenez ces propos c'est bien parce
que vous le partagez et que vous le
défendez tout autant que moi et je vous
en remercie
merci à vous tous et j'en arrêterai là
de donner tout son sens à l'engagement
politique et à l'action publique car ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie avancée et c'est pour cela je
pense que toutes et tous et bien nous
avons toujours été mobilisés déterminé à
faire avancer la cause des plus
vulnérables avant tout le destin de
notre pays sans laisser personne au bord
de la route nous pouvons en être
collectivement très fier merci à toutes
et à tous merci
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Eric
gold pour le groupe RDSE pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission madame le rapporteur chers
collègues 4 mois après l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi à l'unanimité
nous nous retrouvons donc pour examiner
le texte en deuxième lecture après son
adoption l'Assemblée nationale à
l'unanimité également mais avec
plusieurs modifications si ces
modifications ont fait craindre un
report dans l'application de la mesure
elles ont néanmoins permis d'améliorer
le texte notamment grâce à l'engagement
du gouvernement sorti de sa réserve
initiale sur un sujet aussi majeur que
les violences conjugales nous pouvons
saluer le travail consensuel effectué au
sein du Parlement et de l'exécutif
quand il s'agit d'aider les victimes à
s'extirper des nains de leur bureau de
leur bourreaux nous sommes heureusement
capables de travailler en bonne
intelligence près de 300 000 personnes
sont victimes chaque année de violences
conjugales en France 72% d'entre elles
sont des femmes or il est avéré que la
précarité financière retarde voire
empêche le départ du domicile conjugal
et on ne sait que cette précarité touche
davantage des femmes en complément des
aides déjà existantes je rappelle le
téléphone grave danger le bracelet anti
rapprochement et toutes les mesures du
Grenelle des violences conjugales cette
proposition de loi s'attaque donc
spécifiquement à la question de la
dépendance financière qui demeure un
frein majeur pour nombre de victimes
concernant l'esprit initial du texte le
dispositif adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale se décline en un prêt à taux
zéro et une aide non remboursable
moduler en fonction des besoins de la
victime et de sa situation économique et
sociale la présence d'enfants à charge
pourra notamment permettre l'octroi d'un
montant supplémentaire qui devrait aider
à les sortir de ce climat de violence
dont ils sont aussi les principales
victimes
dans le cas d'un prêt et sur décision de
justice le remboursement pour être mis à
la charge de l'auteur des violences ce
qui libèrera de fait la victime de sa
créances cette aide est toutefois
conditionnée à un dépôt de plainte ou un
signalement au procureur de la
République les commissariats et unités
de gendarmerie pour enregistrer
transmettre la demande d'aide sans être
obligé seul demeure l'obligation
d'informer la victime de l'existence de
cette aide ce qui semble en effet plus
conforme au rôle émission des forces de
l'ordre hormis les articles qui
sollicitent les demandes de rapport
auxquels nous sommes au Sénat et au
groupe RDSE généralement très réticents
nous regrettons l'inscription du demande
de loi de programmation plus réelle sur
la trajectoire des finances publiques en
matière de lutte contre les votes
violences faites aux femmes elle n'a
qu'une portée symbolique puisque le
gouvernement n'est pas tenu de déposer
un tel projet de loi gardons nous de
créer de faux espoirs en la matière
enfin si la rédaction issue de
l'Assemblée correspond à la volonté
générale des auteurs de la PPL de créer
une aide universelle la suppression de
la condition de régularité de séjour et
de stabilité de résidence en France me
paraît en réalité peu opérationnelle
chaque victime doit bien sûr pouvoir
être aidé mais je doute que les
personnes en situation irrégulière se
rendent au commissariat pour porter
plainte et je crois que nous devrions
nous concentrer sur des aides plus
adaptées à leur réalité pour conclure
cette proposition de loi offre une aide
supplémentaire dans cette période de
latence que constitue le départ parfois
brutal du domicile et sur le sujet très
complexe de la dépendance financière qui
rajoute à la vulnérabilité et repousse
indispensable mise à l'abri si ce
nouveau droit peut convaincre ne
serait-ce qu'une seule victime de partir
alors nous aurons peut-être sauvé une
vie de plus le groupe RDSE votera donc
comme en première lecture cette PPL
d'une seule voix je remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
Madame Valérie Boyer pour le groupe les
républicains de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur et mes chers collègues elles
avaient 19 30 51 ou 90 ans la plupart
étaient maire de famille leurs enfants
parfois étaient témoins cette barbarie
ou même été tuée à leur tour certains
étaient enceintes parfois elles ont été
brûlées étrangler ou abattu d'un coup de
fusil c'est meurtres perpétrés sur tout
le territoire français essentiellement
par des hommes qui étaient déjà parfois
connus des services de police et même
souvent et de la justice pour des faits
de violences conjugales en 2022 147
d'entre elles ont été tués par leur
conjoint et axes conjoint et je voudrais
souligner que 18 tomes aussi ont été
tués par leur conjoint ou leur conjointe
un enfant est tué par l'un de ses
parents tous les 5 jours en moyenne
d'après l'Unicef près de 400 000 enfants
en France vivent dans un foyer où les
violences intrafamidales sévissent
derrière chez CIF il y a une réalité
celle de la souffrance insupportable et
inacceptable plus jamais plus que jamais
pardon nous avons besoin de
l'implication de tous c'est pourquoi le
20 octobre dernier le Sénat adopté à
l'unanimité la proposition de loi créant
une aide d'urgence en faveur des
victimes de violences conjugales
déposées par notre collègue Valérie
Letard et je la remercier pour son
travail et lui dire enfin une mesure
concrète enfin une mesure concrète qui
est lie Sena proximité et conseil
départementaux et c'est ça que nous
attendons de la chambre haute et c'est
ça je pense que les femmes attendent
aussi quelque chose de concret de rapide
et d'efficace après moins de 4 mois plus
tard le texte nous revient après avoir
recueilli le vote là aussi quasi
uneanime de l'Assemblée nationale la
lutte contre ces violences notamment
faites aux femmes est un combat qui
concerne toute la société c'est un
combat universel ce combat me tient
particulièrement à coeur comme vous tous
mes chers collègues ici présents en
effet je suis engagée pour les victimes
comme parlementaires il y a maintenant
près de 10 ans notamment aux côtés de
mettre Nathalie Tomasini et du jujuard
Durand que je veux saluer et je sais
qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous
tentent de faire évoluer aussi notre lég
je pense notamment à notre délégation au
droit des femmes avec sa dynamique
présidente Annick billon que je veux
saluer pour son investissement et son
énergie pour cette cause mais
malheureusement ce combat n'avant jamais
assez vite voilà des années que nous
demandons une grande loi sur les
violences conjugales et pas d'examiner
les choses de façon tronçonnée mais
voilà plusieurs années que nous devons
nous contenter de propositions de loi
successives et ce malgré le Grenelle des
violences conjugales de 2019 et comment
ne pas évoquer la grande loi du 9
juillet 2010 à laquelle Valérie léthard
d'ailleurs et moi-même nous avons
participé sur les bancs de l'autre
assemblée
celle de Guy Geoffroy qui a créé
notamment l'ordonnance de protection
l'expérimentation sur le bracelet
électronique il a fait rentrer en fin
concrètement dans la loi c'était la
première fois le téléphone grave danger
ou encore les lois du 28 décembre 2019
et du 38 mai 2020 qui prévoit notamment
les dispositions pour améliorer l'accès
au logement des victimes de violences
conjugales et modifier le régime
d'ordonnance de protection prise par le
juge des affaires familiales sans
oublier les dispositions qui facil
suspension et le retrait de l'autorité
parentale du parents violent mesure que
je réclame depuis des années et qui ont
été systématiquement malheureusement
madame la ministre rejetée par les
gouvernements Hollande et Macron avant
d'être intégré quelques années plus tard
d'ailleurs dans quelques semaines nous
aurons un nouveau à examiner un texte à
ce sujet je crois madame la ministre que
ces grandes causes méritent que nous
dépassions définitivement de clivage
politique il serait temps aussi
rappelons-le l'analyse des appels du 39
19 révèle ces dernières années une
aggravation des viols conjugaux des
menaces de mort et des tentatives de
féminicides en 2019 plus de 2100 auteurs
de violence en été déjà rendu coupable
par le passé aussi le texte de notre
collègue Valérie letar créer une aide
financière d'urgence aux victimes de
violences conjugales l'aide peut-être
versée sous forme d'un prêt sans intérêt
comme le prévoyait le texte issu du
Sénat mais peut également être un don et
il responsabilise aussi le violent
conjugal et ça c'est vraiment primordial
qui devra rembourser à l'issue de toutes
les procédures et c'est bien que ce qui
c'est quand même une avancée aussi
considérable qui qui fait en sorte que
cette responsabilisation et cette
culpabilisation et bien elle rentre de
façon concrète bien sûr ce texte ne
suffira pas à résoudre toutes les
failles mais c'est une avancée
importante et je veux rappeler qu'un
rapport de l'Inspection générale de la
justice en 2019 sur les homicides
conjugaux indiquent que si 41% avaient
alerté les forces de sécurité 82 % des
mains courantes à l'époque maintenant
c'est différent et des procès verbaux de
renseignement judiciaire n'avaient donné
lieu à aucune investigation tandis que
80% des plaines plaintes pardon avait
déjà abouti un classement sans suite
c'est pourquoi il est important que nous
regardions dans chaque commissariat dans
chaque lieu d'accueil comment les choses
évoluent et c'est pourquoi nous ne
disons pas assez mais avant d'envisager
d'autres réformes je crois qu'il est
nécessaire et vital d'appliquer les lois
existantes et de vérifier leur
effectivement leur application je vais
citer un exemple la loi de 2019 sur les
violences conjugales a permis la mise en
place d'un comité de pilotage chargé de
suivre le déroulement des différentes
expérimentations ce comité dans je suis
membre qui devait se réunir qui devait
réunir deux députés de sénateurs de ces
réunit que deux fois en quatre ans alors
mes chers collègues conclusion la parole
la loi et la justice ont le pouvoir et
même la responsabilité de protéger ses
victimes c'est pourquoi bien sûr
j'espère que nous adopterons à
l'unanimité cette très belle loi merci
beaucoup merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame Colette mélo pour le groupe les
indépendant pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues il y a quelques mois d'octobre
dernier le Sénat a prouvé à l'unanimité
la proposition de loi créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
des violences conjugales cette
initiative sénatoriale constitue à mes
yeux un cas d'école elle vise à intégrer
dans la loi des pratiques qui ont fait
leur preuve sur le terrain c'est bien
sûr le cas du Nord et je veux remercier
Valérie léthard pour son travail ou
l'expérimentation menée dans
l'arrondissement de Valenciennes est
déjà couronnée de succès si tenté que
l'on puisse parler de succès dans la
lutte contre des violences conjugales
dans mon département de la
Seine-et-Marne la CAF a également mise
en place un système d'aide
complémentaire aux victimes de violences
conjugales de toute évidence ce
mécanisme d'aide aux victimes fonctionne
les acteurs de terrain s'en sont emparés
nous ne pouvons pas l'ignorer c'est
pourquoi je tiens à remercier Valérie
Létard pour son initiative qui répond
précisément aux problé du terrain les
acteurs du social qui agissent pour la
protection des victimes ont montré leur
appétence et leur intérêt pour ce type
de mécanisme comme lors de la première
lecture notre groupe votera en faveur de
ce texte afin de permettre la mise en
œuvre rapide de ce dispositif je me
réjouis que l'assemblée est également
adoptée ce texte et que le gouvernement
est choisi de le soutenir ce soutien est
décisif parce qu'il témoignent de la
volonté partagée de voir ce dispositif
compléter toutes les actions déjà mises
en place par le gouvernement l'examen à
l'assemblée a permis de corriger les
quelques lacunes du texte que nous
n'avons malheureusement pas pu corriger
en première lecture à cause de l'article
40 de la Constitution c'est le cas pour
l'intégration des mutuelles sociales
agricoles au dispositif qui est
désormais acquise ce texte met en place
des outils nouveaux et je me réjouis
qu'il fasse l'objet d'un consensus
politique large cependant ce sujet
délicat ne doit pas servir de véhicules
législatif pour d'autres combats que
celui pour la protection des victimes de
violences conjugales c'est pourquoi
j'avais déposé un amendement que j'ai
retiré avant la séance son objet était
de modifier à la marge la rédaction de
l'article premier terme cet article visa
instaurer une loi de programmation pour
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes notre groupe est plutôt favorable
au principe d'une telle loi de
programmation qui permettra de mettre en
cohérence les objectifs et les moyens
mobilisés à cette fin cela nous donnera
l'opportunité d'un débattre de façon
régulière et sérieuse mais nous
regrettons que la rédaction proposée à
l'Assemblée ne soit pas aussi appropriée
que celle du texte initial un effet de
texte initial prenait soin de ne pas
distinguer entre hommes et femmes pour
s'intéresser à toutes les victimes cette
modification sémantique est importante
car elle introduit un vieil idéologique
dans ce texte je crois que notre travail
doit rester guidé par le bon sens et la
volonté d'aider toutes les victimes de
violences conjugales qu'elles soient des
femmes ou des hommes même si c'est av
que l'immense majorité des violences se
conjugales sont commises par des hommes
contre des femmes les violences n'en
sont pas moins graves lorsqu'elles sont
pas commises contre des femmes je pense
là aux hommes qui subissent des
violences de la part de leur conjoints
ou de leur conjoints cela peut arriver
en conclusion je crois que cette
proposition de loi créant une aide
universelle d'urgence pour les victimes
de violences conjugales et essentielles
et répondent préoccupations actuelles de
notre société j'espère que nous pourrons
encore améliorer ce texte même si le
plus important est que sa mise en œuvre
sur le terrain soit la plus rapide
possible c'est ce que les victimes
attendent
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Mélanie Vogel pour le
groupe écologiste pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues
sous leurs coups sous leurs abus une
femme meurt tous les trois jours en
France de cela nous devons tous nous
sentir responsables c'est ce qu'avait
constaté Emmanuel Macron le 25 novembre
2017 quand il promettait de faire de
l'élimination l'élimination des
violences faites aux femmes la grande
cause de son premier quinquennat des
actes certes mais si peu ont
malheureusement suivi cette annonce et
quoi qu'on en dise une chose est claire
l'objectif d'éliminer les violences
faites aux femmes n'a pas été atteint
213000 femmes sont victimes de violences
conjugales en France chaque année 147
féminicides en 2022 c'est 25% de plus
qu'en 2021 depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un fait
implacable les féminicides n'ont pas
baissé et au contraire ils ont en
réalité augmentée c'est aussi pour cela
que les parlementaires ont pris le
relais et ce n'est pas rien je crois de
débattre aujourd'hui d'une proposition
de loi et non d'un projet je donc encore
la proposition de loi de Valérie dattard
et je veux la remercier encore une fois
d'avoir proposé ce texte une étape
importante dans le combat contre les
violences faites aux femmes par leur
conjoint ou ex-conjoint avec mon groupe
je peux vous en assurer nous soutenant
votre proposition et comme en première
lecture nous voterons en faveur de ce
texte
ce texte est important parce que il vise
à traiter un des grands obstacles à la
mise en sécurité des victimes de
violences conjugales qu'est la barrière
économique le revenu des femmes est en
moyenne inférieur de 22% celui des
hommes même si nous sommes plus diplômés
et dans les couples hétérosexuels
l'écart est encore plus grand les hommes
gagnent en moyenne 47% de plus que leur
conjointe et dans cette inégalité se
loge le mécanisme de la dépendance
l'absence d'autonomie financière encore
plus effrayante lorsque des enfants sont
en jeu et donc un des blocages majeurs
au départ des femmes victimes de
violence au-delà des inégalités de
revenus il existe par ailleurs dans de
nombreux cas de violences conjugales des
violences économiques c'est-à-dire la
mise en place d'une stratégie d'emprise
financière sur la victime par exemple
l'absence d'accès aux comptes de pouvoir
dessiner le financier le contrôle des
dépenses etc et ces mécanismes
se mettent souvent en place lorsque
l'éventualité d'un départ effleure les
conjoints violents or on sait que nous
sommes là autour de la rupture et du
départ au moment de l'annonce de la
séparation ou de la survenue de sa
crainte chez le conjoint violent au
moment le plus dangereux pour la victime
de violence car c'est là à ce moment-là
qu'elle risque le plus la mort les
féministes l'ont collé sur les murs elle
le quitte il la tue en prévoyant des
aides financières pour les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales la
proposition loi vise justement à trouver
une réponse à ces situations dramatiques
dans la première version du texte la
participation financière n'était
proposée qu'en termes de prêt aux femmes
victimes de violence et pouvait donc
constituer une dette à rembourser et dès
la première lecture j'avais souligné
avec mon groupe que on ne pouvait pas se
limiter à un prêt comme l'ont d'ailleurs
fait mes collègues écologistes à
l'Assemblée nationale je salue donc le
fait que comme nous l'avions porté en
première lecture et grâce à la
mobilisation de nos collègues à
l'Assemblée et à la volonté au soutien
de le ministre qui a bien voulu lever le
gage et autoriser un certain nombre de
d'avancées favorables le texte prévoit
désormais une aide financière d'urgence
aux victimes de violences conjugales qui
peut prendre la forme d'un prêt ou d'une
prestation non remboursable je me
félicite aussi que désormais le montant
de l'aide puis cette moduler selon
l'évaluation des besoins de la personne
et que le remboursement puisse être
imputé aux auteurs de violence enfin je
rappelle que ce texte ne peut être
qu'une première brique car notre horizon
politique ça doit être la diminution des
cas de violence eux-mêmes et pour cela
toujours la même chose nous demandons 2
milliards contre les violences de genre
1% du PIB pour protéger 50% de la
population c'est ce que nous
continuerons à demander pour la
prévention pour la formation pour la
mise à l'abri pour que le décompte
macabre des féminicides cessent nous
hanter je vous remercie
merci sa collègue la parole est
maintenant madame on a déjà vu pour le
groupe RDPI pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le texte que nous aimons
examinons ce matin en deuxième lecture
et que nous nous apprêtons à adopter
définitivement en tant que créer une
aide universelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales en tout
premier lieu je veux ici saluer
l'engagement de la vice-présidente du
Sénat Valérie léthard à l'initiative de
cette proposition de loi mon groupe se
prononcera comme il l'a fait en première
lecture en faveur de ce dispositif
pertinent et déjà expérimenté madame la
sénatrice dans votre département notre
approbation est d'autant plus assurée
que le dispositif a répondu à certaines
des interrogations dont nous avions fait
part et sur lesquels je reviendrai plus
tard cette proposition de loi prévoit
donc un soutien financier dont les
conditions d'octroi ont été précisées
ici en octobre dernier rendu accessible
rapidement dans un moment d'urgence
il doit permettre aux victimes en
souffrance d'être accompagnés
lorsqu'elles prennent cette décision
difficile de quitter l'environnement
violent cette prise de décision dans
notamment en raison d'une dépendance
financière nous le savons peut-être
retardés voire même empêcher et cela il
faut l'éviter absolument c'est pourquoi
cette nouvelle aide prendra la forme
d'un prêt à taux zéro versé en trois
mensualités les versements se feront
soit par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales soit par les caisses de
mutualité sociale agricole dans un délai
de principe de 3 à 5 jours ouvrés après
la demande le texte prévoit
l'application de cette loi dans les
départements et régions d'outre-mer nous
nous en félicitons enfin nous l'avions
souligné préalablement la notion de prêt
pouvait être source d'insécurité pour
les personnes les plus précaires
les modifications apportées à
l'Assemblée nationale ont permis de
répondre à notre inquiétude en prévoyant
que cette aide pourrait être non
remboursable en fonction de la situation
financière et sociale et le cas échéant
de la présence d'enfants et c'est une
belle avancée je rappelle ici les
chiffres glaçons il faut les regarder en
face 122 féminicides au sein du couple
ont été recensés en 2021 près de 160 000
plaintes pour violences conjugales
enregistrées en 2020 et la réalité
pourrait être proche du double si la
règle première en droit civile et
piednale est de sortir l'auteur des
violences du domicile conjugal et non la
victime dans les faits c'est la victime
qui va d'abord s'en aller nous le savons
et il faut le prendre en compte cette
avance financière doit aussi pour jouer
tout son rôle aller de paires avec un
accompagnement social et professionnel
cela est prévu et elle doit aussi être
connue et accessible c'est pourquoi
l'article 2 prévoit que l'officier ou
l'agent de police judiciaire qui soit
une plainte devra en informer la victime
il devra également enregistrer la
demande et la transmettre à la CAF
compétente ainsi qu'au Conseil
départemental chef de file de l'action
sociale il sera important de pouvoir
évaluer le fonctionnement de modalités
d'accompagnement et cela est également
prévu pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
RDPI votre a bien évidemment se texte et
je voudrais conclure par le rappel d'une
autre information essentielle le 39 19
et le numéro national d'écoute
téléphonique et d'orientation à
destination des femmes victimes de
violence mais aussi de leur entourage et
de leurs témoin le 39 19 est anonyme et
gratuit 39 19 rappelons le encore et
toujours je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Max Brisson pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
le président madame la ministre madame
la rapporteur monsieur vice-président
d'un commission madame la présidente de
la délégation droit des femmes cher
Valérie d'État mes chers collègues
depuis 2019 le Sénat débattu de
plusieurs textes majeurs sur les
violences conjugales accélération de la
délivrance des ordonnances protection
renforcement du déploiement des
bracelets anti rapprochement et des
téléphones graves d'Angers levé du sucre
médical l'attribution facilité de
logements d'urgence autant de mesures
désormais gravées dans la loi et dans la
mise en oeuvre parfois trop frileuse a
commencé l'accélération de la cadence
des travaux du Parlement attestent dans
tous les cas d'une prise de conscience
profonde de l'urgence agir ces diverses
mesures ont tenté de compenser quelque
peu le retard que nous avons pris sur ce
sujet ou combien majeur et quel retard
quand l'on pense que dans notre pays la
première étude de Statistique sur les
violences conjugales ne datent que de
cependant malgré volontariste vos
politiques récents et des moyens
supplémentaires la croissance du nombre
de violences conjugales demeurent les
difficultés inhérentes à leur prise en
charge persistent et les crimes violents
continuent de briser des vies et des
familles nous devons continuer les
efforts et intensifiés encore la lutte
contre le fléau des violences conçues
conjugales dans ce contexte cette
proposition de loi instaurant une aide
d'urgence une avance sans intérêt ou une
aide de mise en place aisée que Valérie
léthard a justement voulu universel et
la bienvenue une aide pour aider les
femmes à quitter une personne violente
et a scindoyer dans la durée chers
collègues plus encore que bienvenue elle
sonne comme une évidence dans cette aide
et primordiale primordial parce qu'elle
envoie un message fort dans un moment
particulièrement éprouvant pour la
victime nous savons extraire de
l'enfermement que l'on subit au côté
d'un compagnon violent est un saut dans
l'inconnu ce moment là celui de la
rupture et souvent le plus dangereux
c'est là que tout peut basculer vers le
drame et c'est précisément pour ces
raisons que de nombreuses victimes
préfèrent le statu quo aussi
insupportable soit-il aide universelle
l'aide d'universel d'urgence permettra
donc de lever une partie de cette
inconnue et de soutenir les victimes
dans cet acte de courage primordial
aussi parce qu'elle ne répondra pas
seulement à des besoins matériels
essentiels elle donnera le signal dans
soutien de la société à la victime dans
une situation de crise elle camera la
compréhension de leurs difficultés et la
portera une réponse aux questions
matérielles qui retarde ou pire encore
empêche la victime de violence
conjugales de briser l'emprise dans un
moment de crise elle suscite elle
suscitera de la confiance et donnera un
appui en quelques mots cette aide
universelle d'urgence permettra à la
violence à la victime d'entrevoir un
après
je salue donc cette avancée majeure qui
nous rassemble pour faire progresser
l'aide aux victimes de violence
conjugales je salue tout
particulièrement notre collègue Valérie
d'État qui a porté cette proposition de
loi
issue d'un travail de terrain collectif
qui a conduit à imaginer ce système
d'avance indispensable pour que les
victimes sortent de la dépendance
matérielle que le repose leur conjoint
violent au-delà du dispositif qui sera
créé la méthodologie empruntée pour
aboutir à l'instauration de cette aide
est exemplaire elle se fonde sur
l'écoute de l'ensemble des acteurs
intervenants dans les domaines du
médico-social du soutien psychologique
de l'aide juridique du logement et de
l'insertion professionnelle la manière
dont a été pensée ce dispositif nous
rappelle qu'à matière de violence
conjugale seule une approche
multidimensionnelle avec notamment les
collectivités locales
les associations les travailleurs
sociaux les services de gendarmerie de
police les procureurs de la République
et les caisses d'allocations familiales
permet d'aboutir à des dispositifs
pertinents je souhaite donc qu'à l'aube
du chantier majeur qui est celui de la
création d'une juridiction spécialités
que j'appelle de mes vœux regarde en
particulier tout ce que je peux observer
en Espagne voisine au monde département
nous nous souvenions de la pertinence de
cette méthode comme d'ailleurs pour tous
les autres chantiers car recensés fort
justement
Ian Nestor Laurence Rossignol que nous
nous souvenions de l'urgence d'agir mais
aussi de créer consensus pour
intensifier encore la lutte monnaie
contre les violences conjugales qui
nécessitent encore mieux coordonner les
acteurs et de supprimer ces terribles
trous dans la raquette dans laquelle
malheureusement sans gouffre encore trop
souvent les auteurs dans l'attente
madame la ministre
grande loi de lutte contre les violences
conjugales le groupe les républicains
votera bien entendu conforme cette
proposition de loi attendue et utile
merci chers Valérie d'État merci
un collègue la discussion générale est
close nous passons à la discussion du
texte de la commission
article 1er je le mets aux voix qui est
pour
quiconque
[Musique]
chers collègue en dehors des articles 2
bis C3 qui sont supprimés est-ce que je
peux considérer en les appelant
naturellement que le vote est identique
sur tous les articles oui donc article
premier bis article premier de thé
article 2 de terre de quater de
quinquiès sont adoptés et je mets au
voile l'ensemble du texte de la
proposition de loi qui est pour
tu es contre qui s'abstient la
proposition de loi est adoptée à
l'unanimité
donc il est pas là
le président plutôt ah madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président un
mot très rapide je voulais le chevalier
de terre au nom de la prendre de la
commission sociale vous remercier vous
félicitez pour pour les travaux mais
d'une façon générale je voulais
remercier l'ensemble des sénateurs pour
leur mobilisation sur cette grande cause
qui nous anime tous et donc c'est
l'occasion à la fois de remercier
féliciter et de porter un excuse-moi les
sénatrice et les sénateurs c'est bien la
remarque est importante excusez-moi et
je voulais en profiter notamment pour
porter un message auprès de Madame le
Ministre pour vous dire que d'une façon
générale c'est uneanimité portée ici
dans l'hémicycle montre combien le sujet
nous anime tous et je crois qu'il est
vraiment important
urgent que nous ayons et les sénatrices
et des sénateurs l'occasion de pouvoir
vous accompagner dans un texte global
sur les fluence vetofan c'est une
volonté à la fois de la commission mais
d'une façon générale du Sénat et vous
aurez ici des partenaires dans
l'unanimité dès lors que nous avons tous
la capacité de nous mobiliser quel que
soit nos rond c'est un message que je
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
dis donc mesdames les sénateurs moi
aussi je suis émue de l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi à l'unanimité
alors bien sûr merci cher Valley riletta
pour cette proposition merci pour la
qualité de nos échanges aussi merci à
Madame la rapporteur cher Jocelyne
guidez pour pour tout le travail
effectué
je suis heureuse aussi que nous ayons pu
ajouter donc la possibilité du don pour
la forme de cette aide universelle
d'urgence à laquelle nous nous tenons
vraiment très fermement et puis nous
allons maintenant nous attaquer à
l'élaboration du décret pour que très
vite cette loi puisse effectivement être
mise en oeuvre je tiens aussi puisque
vous me le permettez vous me donnez
l'occasion de le dire aussi chez Louise
président saluer le travail constant est
toujours constructif que nous menons
avec la délégation droit des femmes et
notamment sa présidente chère Annick
Bilon et puis bien sûr le travail
continue chez Laurence rossignols Marx
Brisson et vous savez combien pour moi
cette notion de justice spécialisée et
fondamentale je maintiendrai toujours
que ces violences ne sont pas des
infractions comme les autres et qu'elle
nécessite un traitement et une prise en
charge spécifique
nous allons bientôt
pouvoir recevoir le rapport justement
effectué par les deux parlementaires que
sont donc la sénatrice Dominique Verrien
et la députée Émilie Chandler sur ce
sujet et vous pouvez compter sur moi je
sais aussi que je peux compter sur vous
je pense que nous avons vraiment un
message unique aujourd'hui c'est que
face à ces violences et bien seule
l'union fait la force voilà merci à vous
toutes et tous
[Musique]